Welcome to this special bonus episode of Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association. Speaking of Psychology explores the connections between psychological science and everyday life. I'm your host, Kim Mills. Turn on the evening news or open a newspaper these days, and there's virtually nothing but COVID-19 coverage. The story is moving as rapidly as the coronavirus itself. Here on Speaking of Psychology, we acted quickly to offer a psychological perspective. on the novel coronavirus, doing our first interview on the topic on February 10th, which now seems like a lifetime ago. Back then, the coronavirus had barely touched U.S. shores. Life was mundane, schools were open. Most of us had jobs or weren't teleworking,
欢迎收听美国心理学会旗舰播客《心理学谈话》的特别加更节目。《心理学谈话》旨在探索心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是主持人金·米尔斯。如今，打开晚间新闻或翻开报纸，几乎全是关于新冠肺炎的报道。疫情的发展速度正如病毒本身一样迅猛。在《心理学谈话》节目中，我们迅速采取行动，从心理学角度解读这种新型冠状病毒。我们于2月10日就该话题进行了首次采访，那感觉仿佛已是上辈子的事了。当时，新冠病毒几乎还没触及美国本土。生活平淡无奇，学校照常开放。我们大多数人都有工作，或者不需要远程办公，
and our understanding of the nature of the coronavirus was limited. Indeed, it is still limited, but we do know more now, and the United States has the dubious distinction as being the country with the most coronavirus infections today. On February 10th, we aired an interview with Dr. Baruch Fischoff, a professor at the Institute for Politics and Strategy, and the Department of Engineering and Public Policy at Carnegie Mellon University. He's also an expert on public perception of risk and human judgment and decision-making. He provided some important insights into quarantine and the risk of the virus, along with helpful advice on how to deal with anxiety.
而我们对新冠病毒本质的了解还很有限。诚然，这种了解至今仍然有限，但我们现在知道得更多了。如今，美国不幸成为了新冠感染人数最多的国家。2月10日，我们播出了对卡内基梅隆大学政治与战略研究所及工程与公共政策系教授巴鲁克·费斯科夫博士的采访。他也是公共风险感知、人类判断与决策方面的专家。他为隔离和病毒风险提供了一些重要的见解，并就如何应对焦虑给出了有益的建议。
But since much has changed in the ensuing month and a half, we have invited Dr. Fischoff back to talk about the latest developments regarding the pandemic. So welcome back to speaking of psychology, Dr. Fishoff. Oh, thank you for having me back. And you're right, February 10th does seem like a lifetime ago. It really does. So as I said a moment ago, we know more about the coronavirus today than we did when you last spoke to APA. So given that, would you say the risk level, at least in the United States, has changed since then?
但由于过去一个半月里发生了很大变化，我们再次邀请费斯科夫博士来谈谈疫情的最新进展。欢迎回到《心理学谈话》，费斯科夫博士。哦，谢谢你再次邀请我。你说得对，2月10日确实感觉像是上辈子的事了。确实如此。正如我刚才所说，我们今天对新冠病毒的了解比你上次接受美国心理学会采访时要多。那么鉴于此，你认为风险水平，至少在美国，从那时起发生了变化吗？
Or is it the same as it has always been, but now we have more information and better understand the risk? Well, I think it's some of both. I think the had the country responded in a more coordinated and an energetic way, then we would be facing less risk than we have now. We didn't really mobilize for much of that time. We had a major heads up from what was going on with China. Many, I would say, science-oriented organizations like my university and others. Some of the big tech firms began planning in.
还是说风险一直没变，只是我们现在有了更多信息，对风险有了更好的理解？嗯，我认为两者兼有。我认为如果国家能以更协调、更积极的方式做出反应，那么我们现在面临的风险就会小一些。在那段时间里，我们并没有真正动员起来。我们从中国发生的情况中得到了重要的预警。许多科学导向的组织，比如我的大学和其他机构，以及一些大型科技公司，在1月份就开始了规划，
January, but the United States was very sluggish, didn't get into gear. So we're facing a bigger risk now than we needed to have been facing. So you spoke the last time about people being more fearful of things that they don't know compared with things they do know. And this was in the context of how we have a good understanding of how much threat is posed by seasonal flu. But we now know more about the coronavirus, including that it's more easily transmitted by flu. And and that it seems to be more lethal. So given that we know more, should we be less fearful of COVID-19 or should we be more fearful right now?
但美国反应非常迟缓，没有进入状态。所以我们现在面临的风险比本应面临的要大。你上次提到，相比于已知的事物，人们对未知的事物更为恐惧。这是在我们对季节性流感造成的威胁有充分了解的背景下提出的。但我们现在对新冠病毒了解更多了，包括它比流感更容易传播，而且似乎更致命。那么既然我们了解得更多了，我们现在应该对新冠肺炎感到不那么恐惧，还是应该更加恐惧呢？
Well, we should be properly fearful that each of us needs to consider what are the risks to themselves and to other people associated with each of their actions. So when we expose ourselves, then we not only take on risk for ourselves, but we, you know, should worse comes to worse. and we need hospitalization. We're imposing risks on the health care system. If we have a suspicion of having been exposed, then we're required to isolate, then we're imposing a burden on other people.
嗯，我们应该保持适当的恐惧，每个人都需要考虑自己的每一个行为会给自己和他人带来什么风险。所以当我们让自己暴露在风险中时，我们不仅是在承担自己的风险，而且，你知道，如果情况变得更糟，我们需要住院治疗，我们就是在给医疗系统增加风险。如果我们怀疑自己曾接触过病毒，那么我们就需要隔离，这就会给其他人带来负担。
And if we actually have the disease and, you know, perhaps are fortunate enough to have an asymptomatic or light case, we become disease vectors and are capable of transmitting it to everybody. So this is, for our own sake, and for other people's sake, this is a life and death situation, and we should take it with the gravity that it deserves. That also means not overstating it. That is, that we need to find, each of us needs to find a balance where we're doing all that we appropriately can and then kind of give ourselves a break and not worry about it,
如果我们真的患了病，而且，你知道，也许幸运地是无症状或轻症，我们就会成为疾病传播者，有能力将其传染给所有人。所以，为了我们自己，也为了他人的利益，这关乎生死，我们应该以其应有的严肃态度来对待。这也意味着不要夸大其词。也就是说，我们需要找到平衡，每个人都需要在尽己所能的同时，让自己放松一下，不要再为那些我们无法控制的事情而担忧，
you know, in ways that we can no longer control. So how can we tell what risks we're taking when we do certain things? So, I mean, all of us have to eat. Is it a problem to go to the grocery store? What about going out and taking a run or a walk or a ride on a bike? What about taking in our packages from Amazon? I mean, what sorts of things are more or less dangerous? Well, I'm not a toxicologist or a public health official.
你知道，以我们无法再控制的方式。那么，当我们做某些事情时，我们如何判断自己正在承担什么样的风险呢？我的意思是，我们每个人都必须吃饭。去杂货店有问题吗？出去跑步、散步或骑自行车呢？接收亚马逊的包裹呢？我的意思是，哪些事情更危险，哪些不那么危险？嗯，我不是毒理学家或公共卫生官员。
So I would recommend the people to find a very small number. were very trustworthy sources, perhaps their local health department. They're also often a very good source and they're not subject to the politics, political pressures that say the Centers for Disease Control and Prevention or the World Health Organization experience or find a science writer who's been working this beat knows how to evaluate scientific evidence and find the guidance that they have. I think the science is actually advancing fairly quickly on understanding the persistence of the virus in the air and on different package surfaces. So I would say, you know, it may be different now.
所以我建议人们寻找极少数非常值得信赖的来源，也许是他们当地的卫生部门。他们通常也是非常好的信息来源，而且不受政治压力影响，不像疾病控制与预防中心或世界卫生组织那样。或者找一位一直从事该领域报道的科学作家，他们知道如何评估科学证据并找到相应的指导。我认为在了解病毒在空气中和不同包裹表面的持久性方面，科学实际上正在迅速进步。所以我认为，你知道，现在的情况可能已经不同了。
It may be, science may be different two weeks from now than it is now. So rather than giving anything specific, I suggest that people find some of those sources. The one thing that is that complicates the this for all of us is that because our national response has been and remains so feeble in in many ways, we are not doing the kind of testing that would give us a clear idea of how much of the disease is out there. And it would be different if we knew for certain that one person in a thousand in, our area was zero positive or had the disease. Or if we thought that one person in 10 had it, it would be very different in terms of thinking about how one would navigate it. So we don't know exactly what the risk is, but it's probably, I don't know, where I'm
科学在两周后可能与现在不同。所以与其给出任何具体的建议，我建议人们去寻找那些来源。有一件事让所有人都感到复杂，那就是因为我们的国家应对措施在许多方面一直且仍然非常无力，我们没有进行那种能让我们清楚了解疾病传播程度的检测。如果我们能确定我们地区每千人中有一人血清呈阳性或患有该病，情况就会不同。或者如果我们认为十分之一的人患有此病，在考虑如何应对时情况也会大不相同。所以我们不知道确切的风险是多少，但可能，我不知道，我
writing, talking from Pittsburgh, I wouldn't be surprised if it's 2 to 5% of people have some reasonable chance of having been exposed to the disease. And again, because the testing is so poor, we have very little idea where those people are. So we might as well assume that whatever the rate is, it's equally likely to be anybody, which suggests that, well, if a 2% chance of getting the disease from somebody is more than you want to deal with, then it would be important to maintain the kind of social distancing that's being recommended. So I've seen some videos on the Internet of people who claim to be doctors, unpacking groceries and showing how you should wash off everything.
正在匹兹堡进行采访，如果说有2%到5%的人有相当大的可能性接触过这种疾病，我不会感到惊讶。同样，因为检测太差，我们几乎不知道这些人都在哪里。所以我们不妨假设无论比率是多少，任何人都同样可能感染，这表明，嗯，如果从某人那里感染疾病的2%的几率是你不想面对的，那么保持所建议的那种社交距离就很重要。所以我已经在互联网上看到一些自称是医生的人拍摄的视频，他们拆开杂货，展示你应该如何清洗所有东西。
I mean, to a level that seems absolutely crazy to me. I mean, is that really the risk that we're facing right now? Do these people know what they're talking about? And where should we be getting this kind of information? So I would say once again, I would find, I think it's again, part of our national failure to plan for and respond to this disease. There really somebody ought to have taken the best available evidence and translated into the practical terms that, you know, that everybody needs to know, because everybody eats, everybody handles, handles groceries. and because we don't have national guidance that people are left looking for somebody somewhere. So in my experience, the Internet is a, the wild Internet is, untamed Internet, is not a very good source of information.
我的意思是，达到了一种在我看来绝对疯狂的程度。我的意思是，这真的是我们现在面临的风险吗？这些人知道他们在说什么吗？我们应该从哪里获取这类信息？所以我想再次强调，我认为这又是我们国家在规划和应对这种疾病方面失败的一部分。真的应该有人把现有的最佳证据转化为每个人都需要知道的实用术语，因为每个人都要吃饭，每个人都要处理杂货。而且因为我们没有全国性的指导，人们只能到处寻找信息。所以根据我的经验，互联网是一个狂野的、未受驯服的互联网，并不是一个很好的信息来源。
So once again, I would look for science reporters who know how to evaluate evidence. and they may very well have covered it. Somebody that you trust, either scientific American or wired or undark or the science or health reporters from one of the major newspapers that still have them. I mean, one of the confusing things
所以再次强调，我会寻找知道如何评估证据的科学记者。他们很可能已经报道过这些内容。找一个你信任的人，无论是《科学美国人》、《连线》、《Undark》，还是那些仍然保留科学或健康记者的主流报纸。我的意思是，令人困惑的事情之一
that's happened in this situation is we now have political beat reporters covering topics in health and they're, you know, They may have expertise in evaluating politicians' claims, but they don't have expertise in evaluating scientific evidence. Well, then there's the problem of those reporters who are out there, let's say, covering the president's daily briefings on this situation. And you never know from day to day what he's going to say. He gets up there, and it's not so much to single him out, but it's kind of inescapable.
在这种情况下发生的是，我们现在有政治记者在报道健康话题，他们，你知道，他们可能在评估政客的言论方面有专长，但他们在评估科学证据方面没有专长。嗯，还有那些在外面报道总统关于这种情况的每日简报的记者的问题。你永远不知道他每天会说什么。他站在那里，并不是要特别针对他，但这是一种不可避免的情况。
He'll say something on Monday and on Tuesday. He'll correct himself. And on Wednesday, Dr. Anthony Fauci will say something else. I mean, what are reasonable people to think when we're being bombarded with this kind of, I mean, we're whipsawed by the stats that we're given and the information that we're told? Yeah. So whatever the source, inconsistent, conflicting evidence adds to the burden that we're all paying, we're all bearing in this crisis. The standard recommendation in this situation and others is look to subject matter experts or, again, experience. science or health reporters for evidence and pay no attention to science or health information
他周一会说一些话，周二他会纠正自己。周三，安东尼·福奇博士会说些别的话。我的意思是，当我们被这种信息轰炸时，理智的人该怎么想？我的意思是，我们被给出的统计数据和被告知的信息所左右？是的。所以无论来源如何，不一致、相互矛盾的证据只会增加我们在这次危机中承受的负担。在这种情况下和其他情况下的标准建议是，寻找主题专家，或者再次强调，寻找有经验的科学或健康记者来获取证据，不要理会来自政客的科学或健康信息，
that comes from politicians, that even if they in good faith are trying to tell you the truth and not spin it for political advantage, they don't know how to evaluate scientific claims. Even if they've been briefed, they don't have the mental models, the training, the background to communicate anything. So it's, you know, look at political figures to understand where they are in the political arena, whether or not you trust them. If you, if they inspire you, then take in their inspirational messages. But they're, they're no more a source of information than the sort of stuff that shows up
即使他们是出于好意试图告诉你真相，而不是为了政治利益而进行粉饰，他们也不知道如何评估科学主张。即使他们听取了简报，他们也没有心理模型、训练和背景来传达任何东西。所以，你知道，看看政治人物，了解他们在政治舞台上的立场，无论你是否信任他们。如果他们激励了你，那就接受他们的励志信息。但他们并不是信息来源，就像出现在社交媒体上的那些东西一样。
in social media. So health people and scientists for health and science information, politicians for politics. There's a lot of talk out there about exponential growth of the coronavirus infections. What exactly does that mean? You've studied flu, for example. Does the flu grow exponentially? Is this something that we see on a regular basis with other kinds of illnesses? So any transmissible disease has a what they call a reproduction factor. And the technical term is R not. And it's basically for each person who gets to the disease, how many people get the disease from them? So measles has an R not, a reproduction factor in the teens.
所以，健康和科学信息要找健康人士和科学家，政治信息要找政客。外面有很多关于新冠病毒感染呈指数级增长的讨论。这到底是什么意思？你研究过流感，例如，流感会呈指数级增长吗？这是我们在其他类型的疾病中经常看到的情况吗？所以任何传染性疾病都有一个所谓的繁殖系数。技术术语是R0。它基本上是对于每个感染该疾病的人，有多少人从他们那里感染了该疾病？所以麻疹的R0，即繁殖系数在十几左右。
So for those who have had any experience with it, it just spreads like wildfire, which means that It says like, well, it seems as though at the time we're writing as though the reproduction factor for, for the current virus is maybe two or three. So that means that for each person who gets it, say another two people get it. But then each of those gives it to another people and each of those gives it to two additional people. Well, so eventually it raises to the – it's two to some exponent by the time you cascade it. That's why it's so important in places like South Korea where they have done – or Singapore, where they've done an effective job or much more effective job than we have at containing the disease as they do a lot of testing.
所以对于那些有经验的人来说，它就像野火一样蔓延，这意味着，嗯，在我们写作时，当前病毒的繁殖系数似乎可能是2或3。这意味着对于每个感染者，会有另外两个人感染。然后这些人中的每一个又会传染给其他人，而这些人中的每一个又会传染给另外两个人。嗯，所以最终它会上升到——当你级联时，它是2的某个指数。这就是为什么在韩国或新加坡这样做得有效，或者比我们做得有效得多的地方，他们进行大量检测以控制疾病，这非常重要。
They find that first person. as quickly as they can, they trace everybody who they might have exposed and who might subsequently expose other people so that you stop that cascade. You can only do that if you do a lot of testing and have really mobilized your resources. From an intuitive perspective, though, it's hard to see how those probabilities, either how that exponential process that two and then four, then eight, then 16 mounts up. And it's a situation where even if you have a degree in math like I do, you know, know how to do the calculations, your intuitions will lead you wrong. So you really have to look at the numbers. If somebody says
他们会尽快找到第一个人，追踪所有可能被他传染以及可能随后传染给其他人的人，从而阻止这种级联。只有在进行大量检测并真正调动资源的情况下，你才能做到这一点。然而，从直觉的角度来看，很难看出那些概率，无论是那种2、4、8、16的指数过程是如何累积的。即使你像我一样拥有数学学位，知道如何进行计算，你的直觉也会引导你走向错误。所以你真的必须看数字。如果有人说
this is where, this is where it's going and they've done a trustworthy peer-reviewed analysis, then believe their numbers, not your intuition. So there are different models out there right now, though. I mean, how do we know which ones to believe? And some of them do seem to be coming from reputable sources. So the models, what they do, they do things like that. They say, well, what's the probability that they put together pieces and then do the math for you? So they say, how many people have it?
这就是它发展的方向，并且他们进行了值得信赖的同行评审分析，那么相信他们的数字，而不是你的直觉。不过，现在有不同的模型。我的意思是，我们怎么知道该相信哪一个？其中一些似乎确实来自可靠的来源。所以模型，它们所做的是，它们做这样的事情。它们说，嗯，它们把碎片拼凑在一起，然后为你做数学计算。所以它们说，有多少人患病？
How many people will they give it to? what percentage of those people will need hospitalization. What's our ability to reduce that transmission rate by social distancing? And they just do the math for you. And you could never do that in your head. But the quality of the model depends on how complete they are and how good these pieces are. So at this point, again, because we've done such a poor job of testing, we're sort of fuzzy about that we're in a fuzzy uncertain state about the about the transmission rate of the disease
他们会传染给多少人？这些人中有多少比例需要住院治疗？我们通过社交距离降低传播率的能力如何？它们只是为你做数学计算。你永远无法在脑海中完成这些。但模型的质量取决于它们有多完整以及这些部分有多好。所以此时此刻，同样，因为我们在检测方面做得太差，我们对疾病的传播率处于一种模糊、不确定的状态，
and there's also rather little social science in the you could think of this as well social distancing that's really a psychological or a sociological question that is how well do people understand what social distancing is how well are they able to manage it in their everyday affairs Whereas when you're having a conversation with somebody who starts, you start off six feet apart and it's a conversation and you want to talk to one, will you be drifting together? So how well social distancing works is really a behavioral question. And there's, they're very, typically these models don't have the modeler modeling teams typically don't have a lot of social science expert expert expert expert. It turns out that the social sciences is, as they say, unsettled. But as we really don't know how effective these things are partly because we haven't studied them as well as we want.
而且社会科学方面的内容也相当少，你可以把这看作是社交距离，这实际上是一个心理学或社会学问题，也就是说，人们对社交距离的理解程度如何，他们在日常事务中管理它的能力如何？而当你和某人交谈时，你们开始时相距六英尺，这是一种对话，你想和某人交谈，你们会越靠越近吗？所以社交距离的效果如何实际上是一个行为问题。而且通常这些模型团队通常没有太多的社会科学专家。事实证明，社会科学正如人们所说，尚未定论。但由于我们确实不知道这些措施有多有效，部分原因是我们没有像我们希望的那样研究它们。
If your listeners are interested, our listeners are interested, the National Academy of Sciences has a consensus committee that reports to the Office of Science and Technology Policy in the White House that I've, I've just been asked to join that has done a report on synthetic report on social, effectiveness of social distancing. It's pretty technical, but it's also pretty readable. But that committee has been turning out reports on things, some of them quite short, like they have a two-page report on how long the virus persists on different surfaces. So if you wanted to know how to bring in the groceries, that would be a place where you could figure it out yourself or hope that a science writer had done it. This committee just turned out a report on really sort of preparing for worse.
如果你的听众感兴趣，我们的听众感兴趣，美国国家科学院有一个共识委员会，向白宫科学技术政策办公室报告，我刚刚被邀请加入，该委员会已经完成了一份关于社交距离有效性的综合报告。它非常专业，但也相当易读。但该委员会一直在发布关于各种事物的报告，其中一些非常简短，比如他们有一份关于病毒在不同表面上持续存在多长时间的两页报告。所以如果你想知道如何处理杂货，那将是一个你可以自己弄清楚的地方，或者希望科学作家已经做到了。该委员会刚刚发布了一份关于为更坏情况做准备的报告。
It's on what they call critical care standards. So they pull together a consensus of what. the, I guess, the healthcare or medical, bioethical establishment believes that should be done in situations where we don't have enough equipment or perhaps enough healthy healthcare personnel to be able to treat, give everybody the usual standard of care. So it's basically guidance on rationing health care in a situation where we haven't, haven't mustered the resources in order to give everybody a reasonable standard of care. It's kind of, it's a, it's a grim document, but if somebody would like to read a summary of thinking, you can find it
它涉及他们所谓的重症监护标准。所以他们汇集了医疗或医学、生物伦理学界对在设备不足或可能没有足够的健康医护人员来治疗、无法为每个人提供通常护理标准的情况下应该做什么的共识。所以这基本上是在我们没有筹集到资源为每个人提供合理的护理标准的情况下，关于配给医疗服务的指导。这是一种严峻的文件，但如果有人想阅读思考摘要，你可以在那里找到它。
there. So I say again where it's findable? It's called the National Academy of Sciences Standing Committee on, if people go to the national n-as.edu, the national academy of sciences. dot edu look at their they have a they feature uh COVID 19 news and resources if you click there you can find this committee it's got a long URL it uh itself and I think it it is addressing a problem that you mentioned earlier which is oh there's lots of people giving advice how do we know who who to trust of the national academy at the request of the of the federal government has taken it upon himself to produce peer-reviewed syntheses of what the evidence says at any given time. Great. That would be interesting to look at. So talking
所以我再说一遍在哪里可以找到？它被称为美国国家科学院常设委员会，如果人们去national nas.edu，美国国家科学院。edu查看他们的网站，他们有COVID-19新闻和资源，如果你点击那里，你可以找到这个委员会，它本身有一个很长的网址，我认为它正在解决你之前提到的问题，即哦，有很多人在提供建议，我们怎么知道该相信谁？国家科学院应联邦政府的要求，承担了在任何给定时间产生证据所说的同行评审综合报告的任务。太棒了。那会很有趣。所以谈到
about social distancing, and I don't know that we have a lot of research in this area, but perhaps you would know, I mean, we've studied, a psychology has certainly studied social isolation, people who have lived in solitary confinement for periods of time. And we know how they react to that. Do we have any idea about social distancing and how long people will tolerate it? I mean, are we going to reach a point in a month from now where people say, the hell with it, I can't stand this anymore. I've got to have a party.
社交距离，我不知道我们在这一领域是否有大量研究，但也许你会知道，我的意思是，我们研究过，心理学肯定研究过社会孤立，研究过在一段时间内处于单独监禁中的人。我们知道他们对此有何反应。我们对社交距离以及人们能忍受多久有什么想法吗？我的意思是，我们会在一个月后达到一个人们说，去他的，我再也受不了了。我必须开个派对的地步吗？
Well, I would say that's at the fringes of my expertise. I would say, looking at it from a decision-making perspective, one of the burdens of this period is that much of our life is no longer on automatic. That is, we get through life because we've figured out what we've made the decisions about what we want to do, how we organize our breakfast, how we get our kids to school, when we get to work, what email we answer, and so on. And if you have to make decisions about everything, it's a real burden. We're now in a period where all of a sudden things are up for grabs and we've got to figure them out. And that's contributing to the burden that people feel now.
嗯，我会说这处于我专业知识的边缘。我会说，从决策的角度来看，这一时期的负担之一是我们的生活不再处于自动模式。也就是说，我们度过生活是因为我们已经弄清楚了我们想要做什么，我们如何安排早餐，如何送孩子上学，什么时候上班，回复什么电子邮件等等。如果你必须对每件事都做出决定，那真是一个负担。我们现在处于一个突然间一切都悬而未决的时期，我们必须弄清楚它们。这正在增加人们现在感受到的负担。
An optimistic perspective would be that we'll, you know, we're two weeks into this now, depending on where you are, that people will be figuring these things out, that people are using social media and more traditional ways of contacting people to develop solutions that work for them. You know, people have different ideas and different things are becoming socially norm. So it does, you know, it is, it feels less aberrant now than it did three weeks ago to talk to a loved one by, on the computer. on the smartphone rather than in person. So an optimistic perspective would be by helping one another,
乐观的观点是，我们，你知道，我们现在已经进入这个阶段两周了，取决于你在哪里，人们会弄清楚这些事情，人们正在使用社交媒体和更传统的方式联系人们，以开发对他们有效的方法。你知道，人们有不同的想法，不同的事情正在成为社会规范。所以，你知道，在电脑上与亲人交谈，在智能手机上而不是面对面交谈，现在感觉比三周前没那么反常了。所以乐观的观点是，通过互相帮助，
we'll figure out ways of dealing with this situation that work for one another and for each of us and both the decision-making burden and the burden of not having a habit will lessen. And maybe our tolerance will be greater. So, as you said, we're a couple of weeks into this now. What are you thinking about in terms of your future research? I mean, are you thinking that you're going to be working on reaction to coronavirus? How will this figure into what you do?
我们会找到互相有效的方法来处理这种情况，无论是决策负担还是没有习惯的负担都会减轻。也许我们的容忍度会更高。所以，正如你所说，我们现在已经进入这个阶段几周了。你对未来的研究有什么想法吗？我的意思是，你认为你会致力于研究对新冠病毒的反应吗？这会如何融入你的工作？
Personally, I've done research on many different risks, including pandemics in the past. We did a nice project. Oh, I thought it was a nice project on H5N1, avian flu, where we, essentially mapped out what the social side of the response should be and looked at the degree of agreement between experts and non-experts. We did a study towards the end of Ebola where we looked at a national sample of Americans, courtesy of funding for the National Science Foundation, and found that by two, three months into Ebola, people pretty well understood what was going on, that even though Ebola was, you know, there were some clumsiness and its handling together,
就我个人而言，我过去研究过许多不同的风险，包括大流行病。我们做了一个不错的项目。哦，我认为这是一个不错的项目，关于H5N1禽流感，我们基本上规划了社会层面的应对措施应该是什么，并观察了专家和非专家之间的一致程度。我们在埃博拉疫情接近尾声时进行了一项研究，在国家科学基金会的资助下，我们调查了美国人的全国样本，发现到埃博拉疫情两三个月后，人们相当了解发生了什么，尽管埃博拉，你知道，在处理上有一些笨拙，
people were able to figure it out. I think that was partly because there was coordinated national policy and communication that addressed some of the noise that were that were currently having. And we had good communicators. So the people knew what worked and what didn't. They even knew, even gave us good. estimates of what this basic reproductive number was. That is how transmissible Ebola is. So my, you know, I guess I'm an optimist about people's ability to understand, understand these things.
人们能够弄清楚。我认为这部分是因为有协调的国家政策和沟通，解决了我们目前正在经历的一些噪音。而且我们有很好的沟通者。所以人们知道什么有效，什么无效。他们甚至知道，甚至给了我们关于这个基本繁殖数的很好的估计。也就是埃博拉的传染性有多强。所以我的，你知道，我想我是人们理解这些事情能力的乐观主义者。
You know, people, you know, none of us is, it is perfect, but when the chips are down, if we're given half a chance through good communications and, and we have the resources to address, you know, to make and execute good decisions that people will figure things out. For myself, I've been helping some other people with research projects, but because I've decided not to do any research of my own, because I've been working these sort of issues for a long time. And I think it was more value. I brought greater value by helping to connect the different worlds, like this National
你知道，人们，你知道，我们没有人是完美的，但当情况危急时，如果我们通过良好的沟通获得了一半的机会，并且我们有资源来解决，你知道，做出并执行好的决定，人们就会弄清楚事情。对我自己来说，我一直在帮助其他人进行研究项目，但我决定不做我自己的任何研究，因为我已经研究这些问题很长时间了。我认为更有价值。我通过帮助连接不同的世界带来了更大的价值，比如这个国家
Academy of Sciences Committee that I'm going on as the only social or behavior. behavioral scientist. I figure that's the best thing that I can do. Are there lessons from your prior research that you would impart to us at this point? You mentioned your work on Ebola and H5N1. So I think, so I have my lessons for policymaker are to level with the public, treat the public like adults, assume that people can understand, well-crafted messages, can execute, can handle bad. news, want to know what they're up, what they're up against, make certain that you provide them
科学院委员会，我作为唯一的社会或行为科学家加入。我想这是我能做的最好的事情。你之前的研究中有什么教训可以传达给我们吗？你提到了你在埃博拉和H5N1方面的工作。所以我认为，所以我给决策者的教训是与公众坦诚相待，把公众当作成年人对待，假设人们能够理解精心制作的信息，能够执行，能够处理坏消息，想要知道他们面临的是什么，确保你提供给他们
the resources that they can take care of themselves and their family. There's a tendency upon the part of experts, including public officials, to do a lousy job communicating and giving up on the public. And typically it's a case where the politicians, the officials, have failed the public, not the public has failed the politicians. My advice for all of us who are trying to make the best out of this situation is that is to, in terms of practical information, it doesn't change very quickly. You could check every morning, check two or three trusted news sources, you know, a local paper if you're still fortunate to have it, a national paper, your local health department. And that will probably tell you everything that you need to know fact-wise.
他们可以照顾自己和家人的资源。专家，包括政府官员，有一种倾向，就是沟通做得一团糟，并放弃公众。通常情况下，这是政客、官员辜负了公众，而不是公众辜负了政客。我给所有试图从这种情况中获得最大利益的人的建议是，就实用信息而言，它不会很快改变。你可以每天早上检查，检查两三个值得信赖的新闻来源，你知道，如果你还有幸拥有当地报纸，一份全国性报纸，你的当地卫生部门。这可能会告诉你所有你需要知道的事实。
Use social media for social support, not a source of information. One of the cognitive traps that, you know, that's very human is to try to make sense out of any claim that we hear. So you read some fantastic conspiracy theory and you think, well, maybe and who knows. and then that natural sense-making function is useful in everyday life when the world isn't trying to lie to you. But there's lots of people out there who are trying to lie to you. So I would say pay no attention to factual claims on the news, on the, you know, on the Internet. And social media or coming from politicians.
使用社交媒体获取社会支持，而不是作为信息来源。我们人类非常容易陷入的认知陷阱之一是试图理解我们听到的任何主张。所以你读到一些奇妙的阴谋论，你认为，嗯，也许谁知道呢。然后那种自然的意义构建功能在世界没有试图对你撒谎的日常生活中是有用的。但外面有很多人试图对你撒谎。所以我建议不要理会新闻、互联网上的事实主张。以及社交媒体或来自政客的信息。
Great. Well, Dr. Fischoff, I want to thank you for talking to us yet again. this has been really interesting and enlightening, and I'm sure it's going to help our listeners cope as we deal with the huge changes that we're seeing in our lives. So thank you. Thank you for having me. And thank you to our listeners. If you have any comments or thoughts about our podcast, send us an email at speaking of psychology at APA.org. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on Apple, Stitcher, Spotify, or wherever you get your podcasts. And please consider giving us a rating on those sites.
太棒了。好吧，费斯科夫博士，我想再次感谢你与我们交谈。这真的非常有趣和有启发性，我相信这将帮助我们的听众在我们应对生活中看到的巨大变化时进行应对。所以谢谢你。谢谢你的邀请。也感谢我们的听众。如果你对我们的播客有任何意见或想法，请发送电子邮件至speakingofpsychology@apa.org。你可以在Apple、Stitcher、Spotify或任何你获取播客的地方找到《心理学谈话》的往期节目。请考虑在这些网站上给我们评分。
You can also go to our website and get all episodes at www. www.sperectionof Psychology.org. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你也可以访问我们的网站并获取所有剧集，网址是www.speakingofpsychology.org。感谢收听。我是美国心理学会的金·米尔斯。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。